hi everybody thanks for host for having
me I am very excited about going home
you are as well
and I'm here because optimizing is fun
and because I think it's a great
opportunity to use this beautiful
picture but wait the first question you
should be asking is is your program
actually slow by which we mean do you
think it could go faster but most
importantly do you think is that it is
worth optimizing and spending the time
and energy to do that enter a silly
example we have a function that copies a
list of strings that's straightforward
and with benchmark yet including
allocations and we see that copying
about 100 elements takes 5 microseconds
antenna locations we get that benchmark
data and with people if we can see that
most of the time is spent on the append
line which makes sense so we optimize it
we pre allocate that slice and then we
just assign each of the elements and as
expected it's 70% faster
it only allocates ones so that's it
we're done thanks for listening no but
hang on this is a silly example enter a
JSON benchmark Jason adjust this JSON
benchmark it has it is a decoder
benchmark and it runs about a hundred
times per second it takes about 10
milliseconds and it allocates a lot so
this benchmark is slow but most
importantly it is not going to stand
still so we've run it a few times in a
row with a tool called bench come we're
gonna see that every time it jumps up
and down a little bit and this is a
problem because recent JSON speed ups
have been as small a zone as 1.3 percent
so how can we possibly measure progress
with this much noise the solution is
math or in particular statistics you
need to get multiple samples and then
measure variants with that so instead of
bench come we're gonna use a tool called
bench stat which is basically a better
tool a very version of that and we're
gonna collect multiple samples with -
count that flag and we've been stat it's
gonna give us a time preparation but
it's also gonna give us a variance so in
this case it jumps up and down by
roughly 3% but we still need less noise
because as we showed the recent JSON
speed ups have been as small as 1
percent the first question we should ask
is is our machine actually idle now I
shouldn't use my work friends when I
work on go code right
have two different browsers open each
one of them with a different slack
account a couple of editors my email and
so on and this takes about between 0 and
15 percent of my CPU on average but this
chastened benchmark depends a hundred
percent of all of my CPUs because it is
Jason after all so the first bit of fun
that I found out with this is that the
Gopher slack has an emoji called badger
and it's like a dancing patch it's
really fun but the animation on slack
because it's an electron app it takes
about two percent of my CPU so a friend
of mine a friend of mine Paul jolly used
to send me 50 Badgers on a single
message as a joke and that would just
rot on my CPU so that wasn't fun so
close resource-hungry apps and that goes
especially for apps like slack so now my
city usage on my laptop set up between 0
& 4 percent so we rerun 8 iterations of
this benchmark we see that variance is
down to 1% and we can work with 1%
variance
however the CPU burns if we run the
benchmark 20 times we can see that after
10 or so it gets much slower now why is
that the reason is the laptops throttle
especially modern ones and I have some
evidence to back that up this is my
current laptop with my trusty gopher on
top and you can see that the air vents
are so tiny that they're smaller than to
go for itself and this laptop cat has
for real cores and has can go up to a
fairly decent turbo speeds but the
air-vent measure roughly to go for feet
which is a real unit of measurement ok
so in practice this is how I used to
benchmark go code just having my lap on
fire and coming like this is fine it's
just gonna be fine so the laptop
sustains a turbo speed a 100% usage for
about 8 seconds and then throttles down
to about 2.7 gigahertz so we cannot use
turbo speeds because the ventilation of
the laptop doesn't keep up the solution
to this is more tooling there's this
tool that Austin Clements one of the go
team members wrote called / flop and it
does what you kind of would expect from
the name you run it as a daemon and then
it lets you run a program in this case a
benchmark at this address
fixed CPU clock speed in this case 70%
is fast enough so that I get realistic
benchmark numbers but slow enough that
my laptop doesn't throttle so after 20
runs you can see that I'm still getting
the same results a small caveat this
only works for Linux but this tool isn't
that complicated I presume it could be
ported to Mac and Windows so if anybody
wants to do that
I'm sure Austin could welcome pull
requests so if we run the same benchmark
eight times before and after without
actually changing the code at all we can
see that even though the times
preparation changed slightly because the
variance is so high it's 1% bench that
is smart enough with statistics and math
magic it's able to tell us that most
likely nothing has actually changed and
nothing has improved which is correct
but we've skimmed past some of the finer
details such as what count value should
you use or what is a p-value now I only
took one class in statistics at
university so I'm not gonna try to
explain what a p-value is but I'm gonna
try to explain how I understand all this
to work and the rough idea is that if
your benchmark has a high variance you
should use a larger and a larger count
value and I've got a small visual aid
which which i think is quite easy to
understand suppose that you've got three
gopher data points and they're just
sitting there and the y-axis is how fast
your benchmark is so in this case if
it's higher the longer time the
benchmark took so with just three data
points they jump around too much it's
hard to tell if your benchmark actually
got faster or not you just wouldn't say
that with confidence but if you've got
ten data points it is easier to see that
there's a trend going downwards so you
would probably get a lower p-value and
you would be able to say with some
confidence that something has probably
improved here but there's a gotcha don't
search for p-values and this is actually
called the multiple testing problem and
I also have a simple example to show
that we saw before that if you run a
single iteration of a benchmark multiple
times the time is going to jump up and
down because this is a modern CPU
running Linux and slag and a bunch of
other things so you don't get a
dedicated CPU and chase one does a bunch
of things with a GC so it's not static
so it is going to jump up and down now
if you use bench that like we saw you're
far
less likely to see those numbers jump up
and down but because this is statistics
about 5% of time if you're lucky or
rather unlucky enough you are gonna get
a significant result even though we
haven't touched the code at all in this
case I hadn't touched the code at all
and after 12 or so runs I got OH a one
person improvement so if you just keep
running the benchmark and just pick that
one you can go like oh I sped up the
json decoder without actually touching
it
magic in practice no it's because you
were just searching for the data that
you liked so if the data looks bad don't
get new data because if you do that
eventually you are gonna be you're gonna
find what you're looking for which is
probably not gonna be good and there's
obviously an xkcd about this they try to
find some scientists try to find the
link between different calls of
jellybeans and acne and they run so many
tests that one of them actually is a
positive and then the newspapers publish
it really green jellybeans linked to
acne only 5% chance of coincidence but
because they ran so many tests it is
actually a coincidence and if they run
the test again it's gonna be false but
it's already published so don't do the
same when optimizing code a small side
note is bottlenecks much of what I'm
talking about is for CPU bound loads
such as p prof and per fork but
statistics and in our case banks that
work for all benchmarks even if your
benchmark is measuring network latency
or disk i/o so to recap use bench start
to compare statistics about your
benchmarks and perfect to avoid noise in
those numbers now we get to the fun part
or at least what I think is a fun part
which is some compiler tricks to help
you get good numbers the first one some
of you might know about it you can ask
the compiler for information on its
optimizing decisions and if used to
implies that that enables more
information so for example you can ask
it which functions were too complex to
in line so you can maybe simplify them a
little bit so that they're in line you
can also ask it which expressions
escaped to the heap which means which
expressions cause allocations in this
case there's a conversion from a string
to a byte slice which Tosca's on a
location in the i/o package and you can
also ask it information about space
civic features of the compiler in this
case pc e stands for bounce check
elimination which means a runtime check
that when you access a slice for example
the indexes within bounds so debug that
the debug value one tells you when it is
inserting these bounce checks so if you
do found a bounced check in a hot
function you probably want to get rid of
that somehow or at least try to another
compiler feature which is kind of
related is the proof pass and the proof
pass tries to prove things one of the
things it does is it tries to prove when
bounce checks are not necessary so for
example if it knows that that sum I is
between 0 and 10 and it knows that your
slice is big enough then it doesn't need
the bounce check so in this case it does
remove some bounce checks from the ILO
package and you can enable a higher
debug level and then it's gonna give you
internal information which is probably
not very useful to you but it might be
if you're digging into why some program
is not being optimized properly there is
a culture that want to cover which is
when you change your code in some way
and then some benchmark gets suddenly
slower or faster and you cannot explain
why and here's an example Russ Cox wrote
this commitment back in 2011 he improved
part of the JSON decoder and some
benchmarks did get faster but this one
got faster and it shouldn't have
so the commit reads maybe it is one of
those coral and code alignment things
and the reason behind is is that modern
computers are complicated and for
example if you change code it might
shuffle the actual the actual code
within the binary and because computers
are complicated that might actually make
the code run faster or slower because of
caches for example I'm not a hardware
engineer so I'm just I'm just speaking
for speaking but if this happens to you
and you cannot explain why you can just
copy what grass wrote now the compiler
is getting better for example back in
the day is the best way to empty a map
which is to just create a new map and
allocate a new map nowadays since go 111
you can just clear the keys in the map
and that's going to compile that the
compiler is going to see
that for loop and it's gonna compile it
into a single statement which is going
to efficiently clear all the map without
ranging over it which is as fast as
creating anyone but without allocating
new space and something similar happened
with counting the number of runes inside
of string it used to be that the only
way to do this natively with go without
the standard library was to just iterate
over this over string because that gives
you each of the runes but since go 111
if you take the length of the ruin slice
of the string it doesn't do a copy and
it gives you the same result and it's
simpler to read I think so please give
the compiler a chance and if you sit if
you think it could do better and you can
reason about it please file a bug so
that it can improve on the go we should
tracker we use the label called
performance for this kind of thing so if
you want to search for duplicates or if
you want to file above please use it so
we can find it and if you want to go
deeper there's this really cool feature
called Co SSA funk and you give it a
pattern and then the compiler gives you
information about how it's compiling
that specific function so in this case
we have a very dummy hello world
function that just print something and
we do go and say func equals that
function go build and it gives us an
HTML file now the HTML file is huge and
so I can't show the whole thing here but
I'm gonna show the first step of that
HTML file it's how it's what the
compiler starts with this is the initial
as I say representation of the compiler
and then it gives you the end that is
the assembly that it generates for
architecture and in between all the
stages that it goes through including
bounds check elimination so if you see
that your assembly is not as optimized
as it could be you can see all the steps
and you can try to figure out where it
went wrong if you want to read more into
how the compiler works there's a couple
of read means that you could read they
do link to extra documentation and extra
information and obviously I'm not gonna
cover all that here and some of what I
covered here but bench that I think it's
very useful even if you don't work on
the Congo itself because bench that is
useful for any benchmark so there's an
open issue about adding a some
QuickStart documentation for that
package so if you wanna subscribe to
that issue
feel free or feel free to feel free to
contribute
so to wrap up I hope you find NGO
performance tuning as fun as I do that
gopher definitely finds it amusing
that's a piece of bacon I believe and
when you do optimize please use the
right tools and be responsible thank you
[Applause]
[Music]